that becomes a architecture that's in
place and it is measurable and people
are accountable if I could get that in
place then I'll be able to turn up those
standards each and every year as the
science and the technology and was
possible develops and we built right in
in my own country in the United States
our our pension system what we call
Social Security when it was first passed
didn't apply to everybody and here's an
interesting example it did not apply to
domestic workers why do you think that
is who were dresses many of them were
black people they yeah they were I guess
immigrants brought whoa Wow wait then
there was a whole different way of how
they came over so so the the South the
southern politicians they wanted to
exclude as a part of reinforcing racial
discrimination and segregation laws in
the south that when they exclude sources
up now you could argue that Franklin
Roosevelt should have said well I'm not
going to pass this unless I can get
those workers or you can say you get
that set up given those particular
political constraints at that time and
then over time those biases were
eliminated how we think about those
compromises is something that each of us
have to take responsibility for we can't
as I said there's no formula there are
maybe certain issues in which we say to
ourselves if not I'm sorry I think this
on this I cannot
and each of us may have certain issues
like I'd like to think that if there was
a proposal that's today said we can you
know passed a wonderful law that is
going to reduce poverty but this
particular group of people is excluded
from it I'd like to say today knowing
what we now know that the basis of our
society today I actually think I'd have
to say no I'm sorry we can't pass it
because that violates now a principle
that we've established we've set a
higher threshold we're not going to go
backwards on that and so I no matter how
wonderful this new social program might
be I'm not going to abide by that on the
other hand I know from experience in
passing the health care law that I had
worked on in the United States then that
was not the ideal health care program
that I wanted to set up it's what I
could get at the time and if I could
establish the principle that everybody
gets out here and get 20 million people
or health care even if 10 million still
haven't gotten it that's what I'm going
to do now then I'll fight some more
later for the other 20% so to go back to
the point that was made by common what's
true for me when I was a president or an
elected official it's going to be true
for you as well even within your own
organizations and one of the things I do
worry about sometimes among progressives
in the United States maybe it's true
here as well is a certain kind of
rigidity where we say ha I'm sorry this
is how it's going to be and then we
start sometimes creating what's called a
circular firing squad where you should
shooting at your allies because one of
them is strained from
purely on the issues and when that
happens typically the overall effort and
movement weakens so I think whether you
are speaking as a citizen or as a
political leader or as an organizer
whether you're the nonprofit space or a
civic space or during a political arena
you have to recognize that the way we've
structured democracy requires you to
take into account people who don't agree
with you
and that by definition means you're not
going to get 100 percent of what you
want but you should take some time to
think in your own mind and continually
refine and reflect what are my core
principles because the danger is if you
don't know what your principles are
that's when you compromise your
principles away so you have to know
ahead of time here's what I'm willing to
compromise on here's the things that I'm
not you can't set up a system in which
you don't compromise on anything but you
also can operate in the system where you
compromise on everything everything's
under grips that requires a certain
amount of internal reflection and
deliberation okay now with that from
here on out I'm just going to call up
I think you should know in advance that
I will not get to every person so I
forgive me for that all right but I just
try to get us as many people as I can
I'll start with you and there should be
microphones please introduce yourself
and tell us a little bit about very
short what you're doing commitment and
by the way you don't have to ask your
question you can also give me an idea
make a comment if it's a speechmaker -
oh thank you so much I'm very honored to
be here my name is on the whole event
I'm from Latvia and on my journalist but
in Washington DC I was advocating for
Baltic space videos Congress so
explaining to us congressmen issues that
are important for us in Estonia Latvia
Lithuania and my question is that these
days I think a lot of international
agreements are being broken and
sometimes international alliances are
being talked about in a light way but
for us in such small countries it's so
important to be part of skewer and
strong long-term alliances so my
question would be what the leaders of
Estonia lacking was saying it could do
you how in a better way we can
communicate to make sure that everyone
understands the importance of these two
alliances and also this might be a bit
silly but could you sign this piece of
paper who would your famous phrase are
you fired up are you ready to go
[Music]
absolute world war two and the tragedy
that engulfed Europe and then gone the
world we set up a set of international
institutions the UN Bretton Woods World
Bank data settling and the idea was I
think a recognition that you had to have
some sort of international work to try
to mitigate against a repeat of those
tragedies and you had NATO and other
alliances that were established in part
because of the emerging Cold War those
institutions weren't perfect oftentimes
the participants including my own
country operated hypocritically within
those institutions and the declarations
and charters were often violated or
ignored but they did create a structure
and a set of aspirations so that small
countries defenseless peoples vulnerable
groups could appeal to be ideal in the
principle and take that Charter or a
piece of paper and say look this is what
you said and that gave some leverage
some some force to the argument that
over time improved the situation and
then obviously with the fall of the wall
and the the end of the Cold War you then
saw this blossoming of excitement and
opportunity now we're really going to
live up to all these ideals and as I
said before we unfortunately I think
standing on crossroads now a time where
we took for granted some of that
progress didn't tend to our democracies
and our alliances and our international
as well as we should have didn't update
them and adapt them to new circumstances
and as people who started feeling
insecure or frustrated because of
economic changes technological changes
Democratic changes we got this backlash
and reaction to that order so our
challenge now is how do we refresh and
renew these ideas with respect to the
alliances that the Baltics a part of a
soui year referred to protecting NATO as
president I was very clear that there
were no junior or senior members of NATO
and that article 4 of article 5 means
what it says and that it has to be not
just talked about with nice phrases but
there had to be planning and work done
to prepare for the possibility of mutual
self mutual defence and so we
implemented the whole range of exercises
planning to reflect that I can't say
exactly what the United States and NATO
is doing right now I recognize that
there are some strains I think the most
important thing that countries like
Estonia Latvia the other Baltics can do
is to continue to reflect internally the
values of democracy freedom rule of law
so that when it speaks on the world
stage and it speaks in international
forums it has credibility and it is able
to then say but we are doing what we
pledged and it promised to do in this
charter and
and we expect you the larger countries
that are signatories to this to do the
same I think if you I think when there's
backsliding internally then you have
less moral force in that art I would
also say though that no matter how much
all the countries in NATO or any other
alliance believe in that alliance in the
abstract it's always better for us not
to have to test it and that means for
example that the stronger that Europe as
a whole is the more that the work that
all of your peers here are doing this
more that the European Parliament is
reflecting on that or is reflective of
the values of democracy and rule of law
and so forth that inoculates you know
it's strengthens the European project it
strengthens NATO and it serves as a
defence a non-military defence but a
defence against potential improvement so
so I think it's important not to
separate military alliances this is the
strength of Europe over the last 20-30
years has not been because there were a
bunch of missiles fire it was because
thankfully it was because ideas one and
if we start losing the ideas then we're
gonna have problems about all right
Oh jumper right there yeah I wouldn't
know whatever you that's right so but I
think we need a mic very good thank you
it's a great pleasure to be here I'm Amy
Sacramento mom I'm from Sweden with
someone I really admire you I know the
knife you were addicted that wasn't
sweet and then
[Music]
like eight years old of course you are
probably hungry
I wanna do called the Google village and
one of our biggest work is called the
Arabic can we gather politicians with
careers the Parliament society NGOs
effort together to be in a suburb well
name which is disadvantaged where 90% of
population are foreign backgrounds and
we try to build bridges between the
majority of Swedes and the new Swedish
people and they should we are facing in
Sweden and also of course all of Europe
is how do we break that segregation how
do we break that we and them a narrative
that is literally holding back europass
in Sweden's opportunity to accept Roxy
for example is ten years from now thirty
percent of the working age in Sweden
would be horrible I assume that would be
the same day in across Europe so how do
we break that we and them how do you
create a new narrative and you have to
see that in the u.s. to use all records
as that how do you deal with being part
of two worlds and always being handled
by both
I'm trying to build a bridge thank you
so much and if you come to Sweden we
hope to see you there of course I am
going to service in Bruges just one
question but those were excellent
questions look obviously migration
issues are driving a lot of the
political turmoil here in Europe and in
my own country and the first thing I
would say is that you probably have some
better answers than I do because of the
fact that you are working in a specific
community with specific people face to
face and so often the way that you
arrive at ideas of breaking down these
barriers is on the ground human to human
as opposed to abstract ideas so I should
be asking you what works and and you
should be sharing you and others who are
working on these issues should be
sharing what seems to work and what
doesn't
I'll make some general observations
though but the first is that it's
important for all of us to admit than in
every society there is some temptation
tendency to separate people who are more
like me and less likely that's not
unique to white Europeans my father is
from okay you go to Kenyon the Lewis
pink the
who you are always out together and the
Kikuyu think the lugol's they talk but
they're lazy I'm not gonna hire and you
go to the Middle East and you know when
everybody gets here suddenly
oh yeah we're all Arab and you go back
home ah these people those people right
so so one thing to recall is that there
is a visit a universal phenomenon
because humans are fairly primitive and
were still wired to only be able to
process by knowing about 150 people in
our brains and so now something will be
more insidious with strangers that we
don't know and we're asked to trust them
and it goes against some of our impulses
and the reason I say that is because I
think if you don't acknowledge that then
there's gonna be a certain arrogance and
how you approach these problems that the
problems won't get solved that's point
number one we all have some of these
biases in silence it's not just Bill
those people right if we if we start
with that possible that premise then I
think what that means is that we have to
find ways to have the humane intelligent
thoughtful orderly immigration process
that is grounded in our better selves
and our better values and we're going to
have to figure out how do we make the
people who are already any country feel
comfortable with
and that work was education and exposure
and reducing fear on the part of people
who are already there
it also requires some levels of that
application from the people who are
coming in and I think organizations like
yours can help to identify those those
mechanisms that can help both sides in
the United States immigration has always
been controversial and had some level
immigrants adapted to the norms of the
existing society so that if you look at
how the Irish for example we're talked
about in the United States oh it's as
bad as anything you know I was no Irish
don't need a buck there was a time where
the Irish and Jews and Italians they
weren't considered white they they they
were they were considered aliens
Porter's then they got absorbed now
white folks never got absorbed right
that took a little bit longer and so
some of the is simply simply
assimilation that inevitably takes place
is going to take a little bit longer but
some those principles still apply and I
worry sometimes when as we think about
how to deal with the immigration issue
we think that any moves towards
assimilation of the existing
newcomers to the existing culture is
somehow betrayal or a denial of people's
heritage or what-have-you
I mean the truth of the matter is is
that if you're going to have a coherent
cohesive society then everybody has to
have some agreed-upon rules and they're
gonna have to be some accommodations
that everybody makes and that includes
the people who are newcomers the
question is are those fair did they you
know you know should we want to
encourage newcomers to learn the
language of the country they're moving
of course does that mean that they can
never use their own language no of
course that doesn't mean that but it's
you know it's not racist to say if
you're gonna be here then you should
learn the language of the country be
just arrived at because we need to have
some sort of common language in which
all of us can work and learn another
standard
it gets more sensitive obviously around
religious eat that becomes more
challenging and I don't have you know
simple solutions to all of that but but
I guess what I what I think we have to
do in order to push back against just
you know what a clearly racist motives
of some we can't label everybody who is
disturbed by immigration as races you
know that's a self-defeating tactic you
push away potential allies people who
maybe didn't they just haven't thought
about it they may be good people who are
well-meaning they just don't understand
and sit but if they're exposed to do
information and they're meeting people
who are from other countries and they
understand the nature of these different
traditions and they see that others are
eager to work with you've been something
they go on okay and some of the work
that
was done in Switzerland in other places
where you mobilize people to say but
this is not who we are and it appealed
to their best nature's shows that the
majority of Europeans don't want to
think of themselves as mean or
ungenerous or racist just like the
venturi of Americans don't want to think
of themselves in that way but if if the
only thing they're hearing is other
people who are making them afraid or
people who are saying you're racist then
they don't feel as if they've got room
to find their better selves and we have
to continually find ways to to speak to
them and a lot of that happens face to
face which is why organizations like the
or sense of be so important you do have
to figure out how you link the work that
you're doing on a local level with
broader political efforts to push back
against discriminatory unjust
legislation and so the micro has to work
with the magnet in order to be
successful
all right oh you have another question
but I don't ever want to know situation
right now an easy question yes
I'm from Paris I started four years ago
the simple network of shopkeepers etc
services free services to come Mexico
opens a door and are basically our
common chart was a phone good toilets
eat some food or microwave super-special
we use lists physical list with all the
address direction so we can go and
recreate so for me it's an easy way for
a system to be focused and turn sense
savage in three years when we run
startups in France a great idea
the second thing I wanted to say is this
is a perfect example of how if all of
you are organized and in communication
with each other one good idea in one
place can then start disseminating
started spreading to other places and we
can certainly help it I could publicize
hey here's a great example of somebody
you know a small business that had
started something and it's now becoming
a movement but I'm not the only one that
could help their 300 something people
here who all have small stores in there
that may be interested in something like
this as well
so the apart part of our goal here is in
some ways to to highlight good work
that's already being done but also to
identify good ideas best practices great
tactics great strategies good stories to
tell and make sure that everybody now
knows the men is able to steal your good
ideas because the nice thing is is that
you know great ideas like this
[Music]
[Applause]
Mitchell I can't wait but I shouldn't
talk with my mouth full all right let's
see my best canvassing but since this
Emily is all standing up here then I
guess gone don't wear a little bit I see
some people don't worry Billy support
[Music]
and reflections or to find balance I
guess
and in the last year so I've been
looking more into topics of mindfulness
and I was curious to know if you have
any sort of personal mindfulness
practice for instance meditation or
something else and as a sort of
secondary part to that if you feel that
there's any space for more mindfulness
in public
to be able to be more peaceful peaceful
Baltics why definitely think that
there's some politicians who could use
some meditation I can think of a few who
get off just sit there for a little bit
reflect fine find some inner peace no
let me brought the question a little bit
I mean I will tell you that I don't have
a regular meditation practice but I have
my own tunings I guess to take me to a
certain place for example you know
particularly when I was your age I did a
lot of writing and that would serve as a
similar process for me where I would
still myself and if I was writing well
it would take me out of myself right you
become ego less a little bit by by just
reflecting on the circumstances and
world around some people obviously
prayer offers that and meditations with
other tools over but I would broaden the
point somebody asked me about this
earlier what advice would I give myself
when I was a young organizer and one of
the things I said was I think sometimes
we are so driven to get the work done
and there's so much work to be done and
typically our various organizations and
our various efforts work
staffed and overburdened and certainly
under financed and sometimes were
isolated and we feel guilty if we're not
working 24/7 because look at the people
who were working with who need so much
and you know we need to help them and
just a reminder that you can't help them
effectively if you're not taking care of
yourself in some fashion and that means
simple things like sleep or time with
friends or organizing and scheduling
days or blocks of time where you can
just think or read or get new ideas or
meditate or you know whatever it is that
you need
I think organizing yourselves to do that
and getting into those good habits or
working on you know getting some
exercise things like that end up
actually clearing your mind you'll be
more effective you will interact with
people better you're less likely to have
your work influenced by your bad moods
you're more likely to listen and be open
to other people's experiences right so
so all these things that may seem as if
therefore you could actually end up
being for them Michelle is very clear
about this what you talked about parent
she came to a point because particularly
when our children were small I was
traveling a lot because I was doing
politics and we had two small kids and
Michelle was still working and she was
going a mile a minute and obviously you
know she feel like God doesn't do
everything to my kids and she talks
about how she there came a point where
she realized you know I find if I don't
do something to just calm myself down
and be able to feel okay I'm gonna start
taking it out on the kids you know not
in terrible ways but I won't be as as
good of a mom so so she then started
scheduling certain things that she had
to do to get her head straight and I
think that that's true for everybody you
know even as president you know I was I
was a pretty busy guy I gotta say but I
worked out every morning yeah I was I
was pretty religious about it I was in
the gym and people knew unless there was
an actual literal emergency that you had
to block out that time in the morning
when I was going to be working out and
if I did not have a workout I was going
to be cranky but I knew that if I was
going to be able to sustain the pace I
was sustaining over the course of eight
years I needed to have at least that and
the same you know I did the same thing
by the way it's not just but when you
talk about what's good for you
part of it is also social you have to
make time to friends or partners or
something that brings you some joy
because if you're disconnected from you
can't organize a community
have a community you know if you're all
my god I'm out there I'm gonna pull
people together to help work together
then you go home you're all lonely eaten
by yourself get no friends what do you
know about getting people organized so
you gotta have some social network that
could support you and so as president
for example my staff knew that I would
eat dinner with my children at 6:30 with
my wife and children 6:30 every night
again unless there was an actual
emergency or I was traveling I was at
the dinner table and then yeah I work
until 2:00 in the morning
afterwards but that block so part of
what you have to do is to be intentional
about I use organize your time network
anyway all right let's see I promised
that I would turn this way yes you you
do need a mic who's got a mic here we go
I'm a member of the Bavarian State
Parliament here in Germany for the Green
Party and I was running for office after
I was volunteering in Michigan for your
[Applause]
and I have a personal question how do
you deal with all the hate against you
and your family and your personal
beliefs and do you have any advice for
us as young leaders how to deal with
this because as far as I see it now
doing politics for 10 years it's getting
harder and more and more and you already
talked about internet and social media
and the big dream about what good things
this will bring for us and now we see
also the negative consequences and what
would be your advice for us to like deal
with this negative in your own life and
in the blessing
communities or in our parties or
wherever we are active you know it's a
great question so personal answers or
the personal question how do I deal with
it and then I think there's some broader
implications that are worth us
considering I did not I did not read
about myself I did not watch TV about
myself I I first of all whatever the
news was saying about me I already knew
I mean whatever the topic was I was
there
so so they couldn't give me actual
information that I didn't know but most
they could do is provide me with
rubidium and you know sadly I think that
our media has become so splintered and
certainly that social medias become
social internet
people's opinions were almost
predictable right I mean if it were you
pretty much knew before you even said
anything what you know one group was
going to say versus what the other group
was going to say so it almost didn't
matter what I was doing
it was just an occasion to go back and
forth between the warring science right
and I advised Michelle and my
mother-in-law you know don't watch cable
news shows yeah
they're designed to get you man that's
that's that's what their purposes
social media is worse they're designed
to make you click and and the entire
algorithm and mop business model is if
you can inflame provoke anger people or
cat videos then people over house a joke
cat videos are very popular then people
will click and that that means more
advertising revenue for the companies so
so so for me creating a better filter
personal filter was important now
obviously the danger is benefits you're
so filtered that you don't get any good
feedback right and I was fortunate
enough that I had a stand so I said what
you want and then you tell me if there's
something that we're hearing back that
indicates a genuine issue or a genuine
problem something we didn't think of a
legitimate critique then let's discuss
it right so for you so you can't
completely isolate yourself and I
recognize not obey as the luxury of
having a staff so you in your issues
whatever you're working on may feel
obliged okay I've got to follow what the
chatter is on social media in order for
me to be informed and to see how well
our message is getting out which then
suddenly you have all these trolls who
are sending you terrible information and
even if you say to yourself these are
just trolls and losers and they're
everywhere in the basement somewhere and
you know we just decided they want to
just be me it's not gonna it doesn't
mean you're not effect I recognize that
but but I do think at least you should
be able to at least break the habit that
I suspect all of you of a certain
generation have of constantly checking
and renewing it that's that has less to
do with you needing to get information
do your work and has more to do with the
fact that you've been addicted like
everybody else to this device minutes
it's designed to make you addicted and
by the way I'm not saying something that
is you know this isn't a conspiracy it's
it's a well-known fact or acts are
designed and these social media outlets
are designed to maximize your use and
amount of time on them
and we're all victim to it so you have
to somehow break that while still being
able to take in external information so
that that's the personal point that
general point I would make is that we
are collectively all of us I'm going to
have to find ways in which we improve
the conversation on the Internet and in
social media and it's going to be
difficult to do I do not believe that
there is an effective way to censor this
information because you know if you
start getting into a situation like has
happened in the Chinese government or in
Russia of where the government's
deciding what is appropriate and what's
not and basically they have controlled
they're in the filter you know the
potential for abuse is obviously high so
what that means is is that we're going
to have to design ourselves and find
ways in which we create pockets of
sanity and kindness and truth and then
build those out and we have to find ways
to make those entertaining and those
interesting to people and I think that
is actually an interesting project
collectively
for groups like all of you to engage in
to have a what sometimes the technology
people call hackathon to brainstorm
about how do we build lily pads of
sanity and reason on the internet that
we can then slowly grow because I do
believe that part of what's driving our
politics in a negative direction is the
information overload then is coming in
through social media you know if you
look historically each time there's been
a big breakthrough and technology in
media technology whether it was the
printing press or the radio or
television
you actually saw those tools creating
upheaval in part because of the nature
of the meeting and this is no different
and by the way it's going to get worse
with a.m. because you're you're going to
start seeing if you think fake news is
bad now what you're going to start
seeing is the ability to duplicate
people's speech and figures so that it's
distinguishing what's true and what's
not is going to become even more
difficult so one of the things that I
think in the foundation we're looking at
is how do we join let's say a
conversation and the convening of this
group with the technologists and and
come start coming up with strategies and
and by the way the strategies not
everyone is going to work right away so
we may have to try a whole bunch of
different things to see what is it that
is able to penetrate and attract
attention you know and and we'll have to
test them
and I'm always trying to figure out by
talking to my daughters
you know all right like how long's your
attention span you know if I you know I
know you won't listen to me more than
ten minutes but if I I'm only half
joking on that one
but but you know what Sasha's 17 you
know she has a different relationship
with the phone and how she gets
information than I did then I do and I
have one but I am NOT I don't I don't
live in the same way she does so we're
gonna have to find ways to to to think
about information and and basically take
it back from you know these dominant
very strategic operations some of them
are state-sponsored some of them are
sponsored by business interests the
platforms themselves just by nature are
not designed to how do we foster the
most you know enlightened democratic
conversation they're designed to how do
we get more sports so you have these
large both business interests political
interests then are being very strategic
about this space and we don't have I
think the same kind of strategic
thinking around this space which is part
of the reason why sometimes it feels as
if we're not communicating effectively
relative to say right-wing groups
getting their message on to their
constituents in this same in this time
all right okay I don't think I've got
this side so I think this side piece
needs a little attention yes I do you
seem surprised
I didn't see you because you see that hi
so my name is Elin I come from Croatia
I'm not sure is it a speech or question
but are we quickly as well so I will
speak from the segment of a
private-sector social innovation and
social entrepreneurship a little bit
about me I run a social enterprise
called family tales we create fairy
tales for children based on their life
experiences trying to solve their
problems it started as a business just
like turning parents love stories into
bedtime stories for the kids until I
wrote a first fairy tale for a child who
do you have a bearing since then I wrote
about 150 fairy tales for orphans by
myself
and I'm teaching other to do the same so
and I decided to stop the business part
and just to try to build a cure for
these children and turned what I'm doing
into official terribly methodology and
I'm working on it and nothing in on that
path they didn't frustrated me not the
lack of money funding and all this like
regular stuff but the lack of
understatement from government and by
rockler see is something that it's with
a few times almost cost me like giving
up because you come to the point where
you can do everything but if you don't
have a support from the government
you can't implement your innovation into
this world because many times and in
many segments the world is not practical
for social change and for social social
innovation so my question would be and
it may sound a little bit menu is there
a way to trigger the change in in the
government
to make them to start understanding how
important it is to give us to support
other than becoming an activist because
I don't think I can do that maybe I can
apparently you can motivate people so
after you answer maybe look I I do
believe that you can become an activist
you're already an activists in some ways
because what started as you doing
something commercially you became
passionate about it and now you want the
world to know how children can be helped
through what you're doing and that's
activism and the question that is is
there a way for you to interact with
government and and they have them
recognized that this may be a useful
tool yes you're gonna have to be active
so sorry it's too late be already down
that pen but there are a couple of ways
to get governments to be more
responsible one is I already spoke about
you vote even better than voting is to
have a platform ahead of politicians
voters event you ask them questions and
force them to the respond and make
commitments and make you vote so that
they feel some pressure to follow
through on the commitments that they've
made but even when you have well-meaning
politicians and elected officials
representing you they're still going to
be frustrations around government
because governments are human
institutions and they're big and there
are a lot of people involved I always
tell the story the first
the first week that I became president I
was in a meeting with the Secretary of
Defense at the time who had been there a
very long time you know he'd been in
Washington and served seven presidents
and I said hey I'm the new young
president I say God what advice do you
have for me in terms of what I should
expect he said mr. president you now
have a little over two million people
working for you and a budget of one and
a half trillion dollars one thing you
can know for certain is that every
minute of every day somebody somewhere
is screwing up
somebody somewhere out of those two
million people is doing something really
stupid right now which is true because
it's just a big organization and even a
well-run organization you've got people
out there there's gonna be frustration
and bureaucracy and sometimes there are
rules that are some that seem like
sensible rules all right so you pass a
law we don't want some buddy in
government just giving somebody a
contract without first confirming that
the money's being well spent
well that's a sensible rule except okay
how do we determine that the money is
now well spent well now we've got to
have a bunch of committees and processes
and application forms and all of these
flows from a good idea but if you have a
good idea you're trying to get
government to act and now it's six
months or a year and you're still
waiting it can seem frustrated and I
will say by the way your beads you get
it's like a lot of rules and a lot of
meetings and you've got a lot of
governments it's it's hard to keep up
sometimes okay you got the Commission
and you've got the Parliament
when I used to come over for meetings
I'd be like didn't I just meet with them
no that's a different thing this is this
okay and everybody's talking for a long
time so so you know I understand that
frustration yeah but but the point I'm
making is in addition to electing good
people one of the things that you can do
I think is encourage and work with
governments to identify where are
bottlenecks where are inefficiencies
that could potentially be solved and
then finding allies to help improve
processes inside of government so rather
than just complain you know one of the
things you can do is to find some you
know smart young politician who's a
progressive and and wants to try new
things and say hey how about let's put
these application processes online and
so that before I come down to the office
you can tell me ahead of time what
information I need to bring right now
just simple things that you know can
increase in sophistication over time but
can make government work better the
point is I think sometimes we think of
the government as this thing that is
separate from us but if we're active
citizens then part of our job is not
just to get government to respond to us
it's also to improve the government make
it work better so that the person who
comes after us trying to get something
done won't have the same frustrations
right and and that I think is requires
somebody on the inside as well as
somebody on the answer you've got to
have people on the outside pushing and
then you got to have people on the
inside who are willing to be pushed
and it means that when you're
interacting with government having
constructive ideas if you come if you
experience a frustration then the next
time you're with a parliamentarian or
some government official who you're
trying to get action from you should say
to them in a not in a mean way but not
like you guys are terrible and stupid
but say you know I just want you to know
that like I had to wait for six months
and maybe it why is that is there
something we can do I have an
organization here I can be supportive
then you know helping you just make this
office work better in this issue that we
care deeply about and I'm sure you do
too right so there may be ways but you
have to take some ownership over all
right let's see yes right here yes yes
no no no well you know what I'll call on
you just so you don't feel depressed but
this young lady is called on first is
that fair yes I think it's
yeah yeah this one right I need to see
you having your hand up high again for
me also it's a pleasure to be here and
my name is Cuba I am a writer and an
activist and an activist for 15 years
half my life and over the course of the
last year's I realized that you know we
all know how the human brain works we
present a problem and we come up with
solutions well that's out shouldn't I'm
not sure that's how it actually works
but that's something and what drives us
to see things differently we know what
drives business to have a different one
else
two strikes were different well and so
we come up with all these solutions to
different problems that we come across
and all the time now we try to create a
Berkeley try to create solutions for
lots of problems but because of the
gears are realized that maybe what we
only doing is fixing a system that in
and of itself is broken and what I'm
missing is questions like who is our
society designed for what kind of people
do we think about when we design a
society and over the course of the years
are realized that trying to solve
problems might also be a way to keep the
system working and I want to do anymore
or different conversations on how we
want to design society more generally
and also also thinking about
conversations like we have no idea what
it's like to live in a just world we
have no idea what it's like to live in a
world that does not discriminate based
on gender race economic status and so on
and so on we have no idea what the
future looks like so we constantly come
out
cons of trying to change things and I
wonder if doing a different conversation
actually stop fix some problems or maybe
not stop fixing problems but why are we
doing it also think about larger
questions so that we can come up with
true visions not only visions that have
a solution for you know a time span of
five years but long lasting sustainable
solutions this is an age-old debate what
you just described
right which is you start off in an
imperfect world what I used to call the
world as it is and you know like fish in
a bowl sometimes we are trapped by just
what we see around us it's hard for us
to get outside of that bowl and imagine
an entirely different set of
possibilities and it may be that the
world as it should be requires a
completely radical set of new
institutions and new ways to think about
human relationships and you know an
entirely different character
but here's the thing is in the world as
it is there's a child that's hungry
right now and in the world as it is
there are some migrant families that are
behind barbed wire and in the world as
it is I've got a young man who wants to
work but can't find a job and our task
at least I do my task as being how do i
navigate between the world as it is in
the world is that it should be and I'd
like it to be and by definition what
that means is is that I have to keep one
foot in reality even as I'm imagining
something better and yes that may
constrain what I consider to be possible
but this is why I'm not a philosopher
I'm not a theoretical for them to play
also to write and to think and to
completely free themselves from the
constraints of the world as it is and I
respect that
I want thinkers like that who are out
there but in the meantime I'm here in
the mud in the dirt and so there I do
have constraints and I have to
continually guard against thinking oh
okay only this is possible when in fact
if I was bolder more would be possible
but the one thing I would caution about
is thinking that because I saw everybody
doing this thing
the one thing I would caution about is
thinking somehow that change in
societies happen quickly or happen
because you think boldly societies are
somewhat sticky and what that means is
is that everybody yeah we grow up in
surrounded by all kinds of social
structures and expectations and habits
and norms and customs and when you start
trying to radically change things
quickly the wreck the track record has
not been great
it hasn't been so so let's imagine for
example it will just take an example
this wasn't one you use but I'll
disabuse an example right now global
capitalism is creating large-scale
inequality now what we'll set aside the
issue of environmental sustainability
for a second let's just talk about
economics it is creating large-scale
inequality and that inequality is
accelerating and it's a it's true in
every society it's true between
countries it's true within countries and
it seems to be getting progressively
worse and part of that can be explained
by the fact that the more
technologically driven the economy is
the more redundant labor is and could be
replaced it means that if I have the
ability to leverage the technology I now
have a global market
I can make huge amounts of profit very
quickly I don't have to employ as many
people and that gives me a huge share of
society productivity versus somebody
with unskilled and only has been laid
off right now
we could have a long discussion about
that now what do we do about them it is
it is certainly true that we have to if
we don't figure out a way in which all
people feel is that they've got a stake
in the economic order and can support
families and feel productive then
political chaos eventually will reign
and we'll see backlash radicalism from
the right left and resentments will grow
so we've got to figure this out but I
would say that some societies are doing
better than others
if you go to the Scandinavian countries
they're not perfect it hasn't eliminated
inequality but you know what actually
it's done pretty good and it's not that
radical you know basically their
solution has been oh well tax people or
well take the rich people more and then
we will give better public services to
the people who are not as rich now has
that eliminated completely groups that
are being discriminated against of
course not does that it has that
accommodated
immigrants who are viewed as well as
this is program shouldn't be for them of
course not so that's not a radical
change that's a perfect change but it's
better than
societies that don't have these issues I
tell you if you are a single mother in
the United States right now
who's poor it's a lot harder for you to
get decent child care and help raise
your child than it is in Finland and
that difference is a is significant so
the question then becomes yes we have to
continually reimagine maybe even
something larger than that something
completely much more radically generous
towards each other but in the meantime
I'd like to see improvements my only
point is I think we have to be careful
in balancing big dreams and bold ideas
with also recognizing that typically
change happens in steps and if you want
to skip steps you can historically
what's ended up happening is sometimes
if you skip too many steps you end up
having bad outcomes not always but
sometimes oh I promise that I'll call on
that gentleman
you
so and my name's Nick and then brixey
migrant based in Berlin now and working
for Ashoka which is a global community
of social entrepreneurs we have a bigger
bit crazy vision of actually empowering
every citizen doesn't act as an agent of
positive change and my question to you
regarding that would be how can we give
every child as young as possible the
chance to find their power to change the
world so how important do you think that
is but at a very young age how can we do
it you know I mean I think it's really
important it turns out that habits of
habits of participation and voting and
involvement there's a direct correlation
between people who start early and young
and what they do in adult and if we are
teaching young people their power early
they will sustain that power over the
long term I mean it's a Michelle and I
talked about with our daughters yeah we
were actually relatively strict parents
I have to confess in the sense that we
try to give them structured but we
always would talk to them as if they
were adults as if they weren't stupid
about what we were doing so you know we
wouldn't to say go to bed because he had
to go to bed we'd say well you know good
bed cuz you get cranky when you're tired
and tomorrow you've got to go to
and so forth and so on and then they if
they had an argument we'd say okay you
know gives your best argument and since
they were six usually we'd win the
argument because they hadn't thought
things through that much but what that
did was it right to teach us
independence of thinking and a sense of
okay I'm being listened to and I've got
the ability to make an argument the same
is true in our public life in our in our
schools in our civic settings and I
think that kind of empowerment is
critically important and the earlier you
start the better it is and one of the
things that we're going to be interested
in doing is working with groups like all
of yours to think about how do you
communicate not just with your peers but
also with the people coming behind you
because those are going to be your
future voters your future constituents
your future leaders and and starting
that conversation earlier rather than
later
you know the the Friday movement that's
been taking place around climate change
[Applause]
so a lot of those people can't look
right there are too young vote yet but
they know what's going on and they're
making change and and those habits that
and that sense of power that they are
developing now that's going to carry
over for the rest of their lives so it's
something that I think is is very much
on our agenda and we're going to want to
strategize and think about how we can
approach that how we can do okay
good even though I said last question
now I always take one extra line so Jeff
right
[Applause]
so first of all I want to hear more
about the work you're doing and second
of all as is true for all the groups
that are here I recognize that you know
yeah okay I want to hear Obama's advice
and I guess you know what I really could
use a change I've but you know what I
will what I will commit to all of you is
that as we develop a pool of donors who
are interested in these issues hopefully
we can create a consortium that as it
learns about what various organizations
are doing we can say oh you're
interested in this well reach one teach
one is doing great work
you should contact them or oh you're
interested in climate this organization
is doing great work and we can channel
those resources keep in mind that we're
not just focused on Europe so it's the
it's great work that you're doing on
the African Diaspora in Europe but we're
also working in Africa and where they
also would like some financial support
so work and Asia and right so in each of
these areas part of what we're doing and
sprinkled a monkey by the way are some
donors who've been listening and
watching this process that we've engaged
and invited to be inspired by all of you
part of our goal would be to set up
essentially a clearinghouse for
philanthropic efforts regionally so that
you all have direct access I don't even
have to necessarily be an intermediary
in which you have more access to talk to
and and directly work with people who
are interested in supporting the work
that you're doing because I've been on
the other side of trying to raise money
and it's ennis you know sometimes it's
hard look at yo I was talking to some
doors earlier about the fact that you
know the safe thing to do is right if
two of you know Hospital or I give to a
well-established charity because there's
no possibility of controversy and I find
I said to these donors I said look
admittedly if you fund and engage with
social activists who are trying to bring
about systemic change and reimagine how
society might work together there are
probably some more risks involved
because it's hard because in some cases
it hasn't been done before maybe we
haven't been confronted before with a
situation where we had to stop the
planet from getting completely burned
you know we we haven't dumped before
with some of the issues
that we are dealing with or we haven't
dealt with them wisely and well before
so we're creating new models so there's
going to be some risks involved but if
you don't want to see a continuation of
term trends if you want to actual see
progress that you have to invest just
like venture capitalists invest in
startups you have to invest in folks who
are trying to things and yes there's
more risk but there's also more upside
and I and I truly believe it
my belief is investing in you is our
best investment and what I can do more
than anything I think is to spotlight
highlight bring attention to the work
you're doing and occasionally maybe
maybe you know give a little inspiration
but but your work will speak for itself
and will potentially I think not only
inspired others but more importantly
change the world
[Applause]
[Music]
you